okay next game again with black waters
explain over from from Mexico um what
can i play that didn't play so maybe try
French defense okay I have a sideline
here that I can play okay without c5 but
the immediate v6 which is interesting
ideas to cover g7 with its novels and
try to exchange the bishops on a six of
course eih from this is always flicked
in no pitcher base six
the only issue here has all the time in
this winner one line is that the hooking
side is somewhat weakened because the
dark square Bishop is missing of course
them in return you get done let me get
the weaknesses on the queenside okay
might try it on Knight to f4 hmm
interesting do I have what Queen a form
this is an idea still I don't know how I
should should castle difficult maybe we
route this night first doesn't have any
future on the 186 okay just castles this
is unusual ok let's try complete this
night journey
idea could be to either bring this
Knight to c4 which is of course very
nice gram or if it's possible to to get
it to f5 to to block the Kings side even
more maybe he really wants to play c4
don't know that I could easily prevent
with 95 or he wants to clear the way for
f4 is also possible but not sure if this
really is so effective
yeah problem as long as the special p I
cannot Castle long should I really want
to do maybe try to to get the Knight to
f5 and don't block this okay now i could
actually casts a long you might have
queen of three then difficult
that maybe maybe Knight to f5 then you
can just take on h5m if you called we
have three years on as an issue yeah but
I need to get the King walking away them
okay so thinking along completely
different lines here seems ok well g6 is
not a happy move that I to prevent a
five thing okay
I cannot go for see far as you forward
the mode because I have too much
pressure on the phone
difficult lady too looks like a bit lame
to me actually ok let's try to get the
King to I know he goes for this room but
the still should be I'm should be ok for
me I think
came queen
we could also check the exchange here 95
just this letter S ting idea okay do a
play 93 now right Matt don't get I'm
warning light back but I have some nice
play here h4 is hanging and also deform
and 93 years own also a threat okay if I
take now on g4 maybe this is a simple
solution check
yeah this is some think enough for the
exchange cut down the nice active rogue
and the really strong night which can be
also brought to d5 on d5 at one block
the D file please for a while
yeah this is a position that you can
cannot lose really from a position point
of view because white cannot do anything
it's only a matter of time management
and I spent a lot of time
and yeah it's very nice a black but not
sure with the time yes I understand that
is very much content with a draw here
I'd like to play on but i'm not sure if
i can really do this and with this time
okay this is very risky but look like
I'd like to try something this idea
check check check check check yeah that
paid off dick I'll even make it in this
time I think Jack White resigns oh yeah
meta management was troublesome as usual
but this was a neat trick here I thing
is I'm not sure what he can do to
prevent it yeah rookie FOIA he needs to
play rookie form no then we just just
play on here black black as a nice
position but maybe I cannot make any
progress this was really playing on on
this as a single trick here maybe you
just should just play rugby seven or
something okay but then I have been
responsive of course yeah so interesting
interesting struggle you know I was just
hurt too slow as usual